une jeune fille qui essaie de s'en
sortir et qui ne se limite pas aux rêves
des autres
[Musique]
je me suis battu pour moi même pour me
prouver à moi-même j'étais quelqu'un et
je sais pas pour combien les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui ont un mal de vivre
ambiant et et parce que moi j'en fais
partie et j'ai l'impression que je
pourrais jamais être heureuse malgré
tout ce qui m'arrive
donc j'ai envie de leur dire beauté vous
pas
[Musique]
on
aujourd'hui je pense que je serais pas
là où je suis aujourd'hui s'ils avaient
pas grandi en banlieue je n'avais pas eu
tous avec toi pas connu tout ce que j'ai
connu
[Musique]
je suis un diamant brut un faux diamants
bruts en fait c'est que vous enlevez la
facette est bien petite femme qui est là
et qui est plein de émotions et
sentiments
[Musique]
m
j'ai beaucoup plus longue dans ma poche
que ma plume il m'a fallu reprendre des
cours d'orthographe toujours gardé sa
15e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me suis pas dit je suis une femme
j'ai un pouvoir je vais pouvoir dire des
choses que d'autres n'ont pas dit non
j'ai dit tiens dis ce que tu as envie de
dire dis ce que tu pense réellement et à
partir de là les gens devraient se
retrouver parce que t'es pas fait si
différente des autres finalement d'une
cité comme nous déjà là coûtera peut
dire comme si c'était notre vécu tu vois
ma démarche quel est vraiment uniquement
artistique maintenant c'est vrai qu'il
ya beaucoup de jeunes filles qui se
retrouvent en moi et à des garçons comme
on a pu le voir qu'ils y croient aussi
cherche pas être un exemple mais c'est
vrai que ça fait vraiment plaisir de
reconnaître que c'est rare qu'un jeune
soit la télé et que qu'une jeune en
l'occurrence puisse plus dire ce qu'elle
pense et le dire et être crédible tout
simplement
j'ai parlé des violences conjugales
parce que c'est quelque chose que j'ai
subie j'ai besoin d'en parler dans le
morceau ma souffrance
j'ai eu le désir d'en parler simplement
pour informer les gens que les violences
conjugales ne sont pas forcément des
violences subies par les adultes que
c'est parfois aussi quand notre premier
amour et toutes ces petites choses là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ose espérer que même si je fais partie
d'une génération qui se sent pas
représenté et qui pas trop touchés par
la politique
j'ose espérer que des mouvements comme
ça mais ça incitera parce que des gens à
nous entraîner
[Musique]
même appel aux armes dans ma france à
moi
effectivement c'est un appel aux urnes
que j'ai fait
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coc
on m'a volé une partie intime de ma vie
on m'a volé votre mère savait pas on
n'avait jamais vu habillée comme ça tout
le monde a perdu pied à mon entourage
proche certes mais les gens qui
travaillent avec moi j'ai perdu
quasiment grande partie de mon équipe
parce que plus personne ne la veine avec
confiance
[Musique]
sur le voile à l'école elle prend
position sur mais uniquement dans ce
texte
tiens
on essaie tant bien que mal de vous
aider mais comme ils savent pas guérir
la douleur ils endorment voilà et on a
endormi ma douleur et des cache pas je
suis parti en vacances à l'île maurice à
l'île maurice avec le saint coran dans
mon sac et c'est un livre que j'ai
ouvert mes en tout comme on dit ont
sollicité sans réaliser ce que j'allais
liens et ça a été la révélation là on
peut le tien c'était la révélation parce
que j'ai eu une intime conviction que
j'existe
[Musique]
je
m
[Musique]
rappeuse tout de suite ça me donne une
connotation uniquement rap et je peux
faire que ça alors que je sais faire
plein d'autres choses
[Musique]